we see it happening every day it's it's
across the board you know they're
throwing out veterans from uh public
housing to put illegals there they're
taking over hotels paying the owners of
the hotels money but this is tax it's
not like New York's functioning well
right it's been sort of a disaster and
now we're going to spend hundreds of
millions of dollars doing it you saw the
do you see that article I think it was
NBC or CBS News Texas spent a $100
million shipping illegals out of the
state what a bad use of funds they go
well if they sent 100,000 immigrants out
of the state of Texas bust them all over
the country got them out of Texas that's
about a th000 bucks a person how much
would it have cost Texas to keep them
there so I mean the the article is so
gaslighting it's like oh my God they
spent $100 million I'm like that that
would that could have been 10 billion
dollar in the next two years just
keeping them there like you know but
they expect you to not believe you know
beyond the by line or not to see through
it where they've been so it's so
flagrant